hallo herzlich willkommen in Sally Welt
falls ihr noch auf der Suche nach
leckeren aber richtig gruseligen
Rezeptideen für eure Halloween Party
seid dann seid ihr hier genau richtig
die Rezepte gibt's natürlich auf meinem
Blog und in voller Länge als Video hier
auf meinem Kanal also los
[Musik]
geht's Brownies sind ja wirklich super
lecker aber wenn es nur noch ein Stück
gibt dann kannst mal schnell so eine
blutien Gelegenheit werden zum Glück
sind Brownies aber einfach zuzubereiten
und diese hier sogar in weniger als
einer Stunde ich verwende für den Teig
180 g Butter 150 g Zartbitterschokolade
150 g Zucker etwas Salz und
Vanilleextrakt drei Eier 150 g Mehl und
60 g Kakao außerdem benötige ich für die
Füllung 175 g Frischkäse ein Ei etwas
Vanilleextrakt 20 g Zucker und 100 g
fches dann nehme ich jetzt hier die
cookie-oh fches jetzt einfach die
Zutaten für den Teig und die Füllung
verrühren im Backrahmen abwechselnd
verstreichen während der Brownie backt
das essbare Blut aus tiefkühlhinbeen
Zucker und Tonka zubereiten und die
Marshmallows in der Mikrowelle
schmelzen mit der geschmolzenen
marshmallowmasse könnt ihr jetzt
wirklich ganz kreativ werden ihr zieht
einfach Fäden legt sie über die Brownies
drüber und dann kommt das Blut am Ende
noch drauf ihr dürft gerne auch euren
Teller oder die Servierplatte ein
bisschen dekorieren mit dem essbarn Blut
mit den Marshmallows mit den Brownies
und dann habt ihr wirklich das perfekte
Halloween Rezept meine saftig
schokoladigen Halloween Brownies mit
leckerer Cheesecake
Füllung die Spinnennetze sehen nicht nur
auf Brownies gut aus sondern machen sich
auch richtig gut auf einer Torte
deswegen gibt's jetzt für euch noch eine
richtig leckere gruselige
marshmallowtorte die ihr auch gerne mal
mit euren Kindern zubereiten könnt für
den Teig nehme ich drei Eier 150 g
Zucker etwas tonkaavonka und eine Prise
Salz jeweils 150 g Sonnenblumenöl und
Milch 225 g Mehl und Backpulver oder ihr
nehmt backmehl und 100 g gemahlene
Mandeln als Creme nehme ich eine
eingefärbte Buttercreme und dafür
verwende ich 100 g Sahne etwas schwarze
lebensmittelfarbpaste 100 g
zartbitterchokolade 150 g weiche Butter
50 g Puderzucker 150 g Frischkäse und 30
g Kakao für diese Torte dann einfach den
mandelrührteigböden orange einfärben
eine Buttercreme in schwarz herstellen
und dann abwechseln die Tortenböden mit
der Buttercreme und gerne auch mit
Süßigkeiten füllen jetzt am Ende noch
glatt streichen und das ganze mit den
marshmallowfäden dekorieren und da muss
ich echt sagen hatte nicht nur ich
meinen Spaß sondern eben auch Samira und
Ella und fertig ist der
[Musik]
spinnenhorror für die Halloween Donuts
verwende ich mein heißbehrtes Donuts
Rezept aber Vorsicht es gibt eine
Überraschung für den Hefeteig verwende
ich einen Würfel Hefe zwei Esslöffel
warmes Wasser 50 g Zucker 350 g Milch
zwei Eier und zwei Eigelbe etwas
Vanilleextrakt
800 bis 850 g Mehl einen Teelöffel Salz
und Zimt und 70 g weiche Butter jetzt
den Hefeteig aufgehen lassen dann Donuts
ausstechen jetzt im Fett ausbacken und
die Fruchtfüllung vorbereiten diese
Fruchtfüllung wird jetzt in die Donuts
gesprit
für die Glasur nehme ich Schokolade aber
wer noch mehr Variation möchte kann auch
gerne zuckergust zubereiten und
beispielsweise orange einfärben jetzt am
Ende noch dekorieren und fertig sind die
Halloween
Donuts wer jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr
Zeit hat um die Halloween Party
vorzubereiten kann sich auch gerne an
eine Motivtorte Wagen da habe ich
nämlich die Hotel Transsylvanien Torte
die ihr vielleicht noch kennt dafür habe
ich eine tipsi turry Torte zubereitet
das heißt die Torte ist einfach in sich
schief und ist was für richtige
Gruselfans hier habe ich jetzt drei
schwarze Böden gebacken und zwar sind es
schokoladenböden im Durchmesser von 26
cm hier habe ich zwei kleinere mit 20 cm
das sind helle orangenböden und die habe
ich auch orange
eingefärbt ich habe hier etwas
Kirschsaft und Orangensaft zum Tränken
eine orangenbuttercreme und eine
zartbitterganasche das Besondere an
dieser Torte sind wirklich diese
schiefenböden die man ja normallerweise
beim normalen tortenbacken gar nicht
möchte aber hier ist es richtig
gewünscht denn je Schiefer die Torte
umso Co und gruseliger sieht sie eben
auch am Ende aus jetzt könnt ihr die
Böden zuschneiden dann mit ganach
befüllen und die Torte erstmal kühlen
und die Zwischenzeit immer nutzen um z.B
die Deko herzustellen Dekorationen wie
Kürbisse Grabsteine oder eben auch
andere richtig gruselige Elemente jetzt
noch vonant über die Torte ziehen die
Dekoelemente anbringen und die Torte
fertigstellen ich würde mal sagen jetzt
kann die Halloween Party beginnen ich
habe natürlich noch ganz viele weitere
Rezepte auf meinem Kanal schaut gerne
mal durch schreibt mir auch ganz gerne
in die Kommentare welches dieser Rezepte
euch am besten gefällt was ist euer
Favorit und was werdet ihr auf eurer
Halloween Party vielleicht sogar
zubereiten ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz
viel Spaß beim gruseln viel Spaß beim
kreativferden tschüss und bis zum
nächsten
Mal